c'est sans arrêt on baigne dedans depuis
un an mais on peut même pas s'en sortir
serpent pour faire de la porte du
cabinet on est encore dans le colis donc
c'est du 24 sur 24 depuis 365 jours
[Musique]
à
on
en
[Musique]
e
à
ans
actuellement à l'étude
c'est
je passais
on verra bien
rothman en un cadeau nommé pathologies
de claudine n'empêche pas la vaccination
non frais il faut qu'elle se fasse
vacciner d'accord oui
[Musique]
lesquels étaient petits génial je dois
commencer à être plus cher les vagues à
on a vécu les trois vagues avec
effectivement des demandes plus
importante des créations et sur cette
troisième vague moi je trouve qu'il ya
aussi plus de fractures psychologique on
a plus de consultations simples ça je
pense que c'est vraiment quelque chose
qu'on sent bien on a une inquiétude à
gérer des patients l'accueil est
effectivement est beaucoup plus dur moi
je trouve d'accord donc les gens sont
plus stressés
téléphone ça n'arrête pas on est des
êtres humains donc on écoute ces
personnes
donc les gens derrière ils attendent
donc coeur même des gens qui se
déplacent ici qui viennent me voir et me
disent mais là je retrouve pas là qu'est
ce que vous faites deux pays n'a rien à
faire des choses comme ça donc
effectivement c'est un peu d'humour
c'est sans arrêt on baigne dedans depuis
un an mais on peut même pas s'en sortir
le serpent pour faire de la porte du
cabinet on est encore dans le cosi parce
que il faut qu'on tienne agents de tous
parce qu'il faut que le lendemain on
puisse répondre aux patients donc c'est
du 24 sur 24 depuis 365
[Musique]
à
densité population seine-saint-denis est
un des principaux phénomènes c'est à
dire que les logements sont peut-être
plus petit il ya peut-être plus de monde
au mètre carré ce qui favorise la
circulation du virus et la précarité de
l'emploi
on a beaucoup beaucoup de patients le
docteur je peux pas m'arrêter pour
emmener par contre le 18 social le tiche
semaine à moins de rendre plus et donc
moins télétravail aussi oui en seine
saint denis en également des zones aussi
le désertique au niveau médical s'est
pas non plus qu'ils puissent consulter
effectivement l'un des messages
on doit faire passer c'est consulter
dépend d'un symptôme c'est important est
peut-être qu'en seine famille de palm
désert médical c'est plus compliqué
[Musique]
jour réceptive toujours à l'écouté qui
prennent toujours le temps d'écouter
malgré la situation donc c'est toujours
agréable
écoutez a le sens j'en ai rien à dire de
plus que le connais depuis que l'île
existe et est de mieux en mieux et
beaucoup rageur i te suis
[Musique]
pour vous
mais la prochaine dans 50 ans